problema 38 nos dicen en el siguiente
dibujo la figura formada por los
cuadrados con lados etiquetados x y y
ceta esta figura de acá x y y ceta es un
triángulo rectángulo muy bien nos
preguntan cuál ecuación es verdadera
para todos los valores de x y y ceta
pues tenemos un triángulo rectángulo
entonces me imagino que lo que esperan
es que si tenemos el teorema de
pitágoras voy a poner aquí el teorema
teorema de pitágoras y ta gora ta gora
moras y lo que nos da el teorema de
pitágoras es una relación entre estos
tres lados nos dice que la suma de los
cuadrados de los lados pequeños que
también llamamos catetos
es decir x al cuadrado más ye al
cuadrado es igual al cuadrado del tercer
lado el que es opuesto al ángulo recto
hace está cuadrada a este lado también
se le conoce como hipotenusa que esto de
aquí es la hipotenusa tipo
en usa
hipotenusa muy bien entonces vamos a ver
si esta relación que puse aquí el
teorema de pitágoras aparece entre las
opciones ésta no es si es esta verdad es
la opción b x cuadrada massieu cuadrado
es igual a zeta cuadrada entonces
básicamente nos están preguntando si
recordamos el teorema de pitágoras vamos
ahora el problema 39 dice una compañía
textil creó el siguiente diagrama para
un chaleco ahí debe estar la tela yo no
voy a el chaleco veo nada más como medio
chaleco bueno vamos a ver qué dice para
mostrar el otro lado del chaleco aunque
ya está es medio chaleco la compañía va
a reflejar el dibujo por el eje y cuáles
serán las coordenadas de ese después de
la reflexión de este punto de acá bueno
pues para reflejar literalmente pensamos
al eje como un espejo este segmento de
acá por ejemplo el ave que está una
unidad a la izquierda se va una unidad a
la derecha el segmento a efe
este de acá ahora se iría hacia acá si f
está en menos 41 sería 41 el segmento f
ahora se movería para acá para acá y
podría seguir la verdad podría seguir
poniendo otros puntos correspondientes
por ejemplo déjame tomar el morado está
curvita de esta curva de y se haría como
una curvita por acá vamos a ver qué le
pasa al punto c
el punto c está en el punto menos 27 de
modo que al reflejarse pasaría al 27 a
este de acá en vez de estar 2 unidades a
la izquierda que las dos unidades a la
derecha y podríamos continuar haciendo
el chaleco aquí tendríamos esta curva
está más o menos así y éste bajaría así
verdad algo de este estilo pero bueno lo
que nos interesa es que le sucedió a
este punto se al reflejarse es decir al
caer en este punto digamos se prima
bueno pues justo como te decía las
coordenadas ahora son 2,7 estamos 2 a la
derecha y 7 hacia arriba
7 vamos a ver si eso está entre las
opciones
si es la opción a después de la
reflexión seca y en el 27
le sigo le voy a seguir porque llevamos
por estos problemas nos da tiempo de
otros cuantos más
haber problema 40 nos preguntan cuál es
el área en unidades cuadradas unidades
cuadradas ok del trapecio q rst que se
muestra a continuación
rs te dice que es trapecio eso quiere
decir que eres es paralelo a qt y hasta
nos dan el área nos dicen cómo calcular
las así que básicamente tenemos que
sustituir el área es un medio de la
altura multiplicado por la suma de las
bases la intuición de esto es que la
suma de las bases entre dos es el ancho
promedio de 1 sería estoy acá b 2 sería
estoy acá entonces un medio de eso sería
más o menos tomarse esta de aquí y por
lo tanto nos dice que el área es
multiplicar la altura por el ancho
promedio sale bueno vamos a sustituir a
ver qué pasa tendríamos que hs 8 b 1 906
v 12 es 20 y eso hay que multiplicarlo
por un medio un medio por 8 es 4 20 66
26 4 por 26 puede saber 26 por 2 el 52
por otros dos es 104 104 entonces el
área sería 104 unidades cuadradas que es
la opción que es la opción b sale
básicamente nos están esté pidiendo
identificarlos las diferentes variables
en la fórmula del área de un trapecio
bueno vamos aquí abajo
nos preguntan un milímetro es que hay
básicamente nos están pidiendo que
recordemos los prefijos los prefijos del
sistema internacional
aquí tenemos mil recordemos que es decir
de si es un décimo que sentí que en ti
en ti
es un centésimo
y que mil
es un milésimo milésimo entonces si nos
dicen un milímetro sería una milésima
parte de un metro la respuesta sería la
opción b vale básicamente tenemos que
acordarnos de estos prefijos del sistema
internacional problema 42 en el problema
42 nos dice que en el siguiente diagrama
el hexágono lmn p q r estoy acá es
congruente al hexágono stv w x a este de
acá que hay estos dos son figuras estas
dos son figuras igualitas y nos
preguntan que el lado tiene la misma
longitud que m n el segmento mn este de
acá
bueno pues yo yo digo que es este pero
déjame ver que no nos están confundiendo
a ver nos dice que vayamos de lma en l m
n y aquí abajo déjame agarrar otro color
que se vea más vimos de l m n y abajo
tenemos que ir de s
s t ok entonces si nos están dando los
vértices en orden de modo que m n es
igual
atv estos dos segmentos el mn y el tv
son congruentes y por lo tanto la
respuesta sería ésta de acá la respuesta
sería b que es congruente a t y creo que
no me salen muy bien los círculos de
respuesta bueno déjame cerrar la venta
tampoco ahí está entonces tenemos que el
lado congruente al mn es el t